welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and this is a breakdown of the new
trailer for spider-man no way home which
confronts tom holland peter parker with
doc alfred molina from spider-man 2004
green goblin norman osborne willem dafoe
from the raimi trilogy electro jamie
foxx from the 2014 amazing spider-man 2
sandman thomas eden church from the ravy
movies and the lizard rhys hyphens from
the 2012 amazing spider-man not to
mention dr strange
but this trailer seems to be playing
some vfx trickery because i highly doubt
peter's facing all these threats by
himself that's right his backup sanic
and track i'm gonna go through this
frame by frame to find all the easter
eggs and details that this trailer is
hiding this video is sponsored by our
friends at heroes journal more on them
later let's get started
[Music]
ever since i got bit by that spider
i've only had one week
where my life has felt normal
that was when you found out we open on
sad peter parker his face bruised and
bleeding tears and rain seems like the
end of the movie so who is peter morning
who's gonna die well the trailer
suggests mj but it could just as easily
be like ned aunt may happy hogan or
shrek this could also be an ending where
peter in order to save those he loves
and those he doesn't want to harm must
exile himself to a reality in the
multiverse where he is a stranger with
no way home where it rains a lot called
seattle peter tells mj that the week
between her finding out that he was
spider-man and far from home and
mysterio and j john and jameson outing
him in the post-credits in that movie
was his one normal week ever since the
spider bit him now this is only the
second time peter has mentioned his
spider bite an origin we never actually
saw in the mcu just kind of glossed over
in homecoming you got bit by a spider
can you bite me
well it probably would have hurt right
you know whatever even if it did hurt
i'll let it by
maybe how much did it hurt the spider's
dead ned so no way home could finally be
the film the mcu flashes back to the
exact circumstances of peter's spider
bite especially if this movie does
introduce him to the toby maguire and
andrew garfield versions of the
character whose bites and web slinging
abilities took alternate forms peter and
mj swing past j jonah jameson's daily
vehicle broadcast until it switches to
his own face half-mast with public enemy
number one number one does no one care
that nexus witches exist just go talk to
those survivors in westview or to mr
dell you know being a man of science
witches and in the shot you can see how
mj's hair is blocking peter's view and
that nearly causes him to smack right
into that screen and only when it clears
does he finally whip to the side then
peter and mj perch on the queensborough
bridge you can see over to the side
there this is right next to the
roosevelt island tramway the setting of
green goblin showdown with toby maguire
peter parker in the first rainy
spider-man film let's move on
[Music]
when you botched that spell where you
wanted everyone to forget the peter
parker spider-man
we started getting some visitors
as peter and mj jump from that bridge
you can see mj is wearing the same joan
of arc t-shirt that she wore at the end
far from home which in addition to being
a reflection of mj's feminine pride was
itself an easter egg holly back
zendaya's joan of arc look at the 2018
met gala then they glide through the
subway tunnels somehow missing morbius
despite his best efforts to sneak into
this universe and obviously they do this
to escape the helicopters tracking them
but also following cap's advice for how
best to escape the city
you take them to the basement or to the
subway you keep them off the streets
someone's been watching his cat psas and
then as they nearly run into a train for
a brief second the train screen flashes
red and m the m train that's right
spider-man narrowly avoided the mepisto
train run all you want spider-man we all
float down here
nah alright earbuds the m line actually
runs through queens so this train is
likely coming from queens and peter's
just trying to get home but there's no
way home thanks emma
now you'll notice benedict cumberbatch's
audio sound stitched together here when
you botched that spell where you wanted
everyone to forget the peter parker
spider-man as many of his off-screen
lines actually sound in this trailer
there are others out there we need to
send them back they're starting to come
through
and i can't stop him this is the first
time for me in the marvel universe
i am guessing that cumberbatch is just
so fluid with his line reads with more
revelatory terms bleeding into the
trailer dialogue making it harder to cut
around now the from behind shot of peter
shows him wearing a dark blue jacket
clearly a different scene than the shot
of peter with the plaid shirt when the
spell occurs him in the jacket actually
matches with the shot of the first
trailer where the lizard was swiping at
peter so doctor strange may have
actually caught the lizard on his own
while peter was dealing with doc rock
and goblin on the bridge we see more of
the exact moment that peter tampers with
the spell causing the golden bands to
tremble and then explode outward and
again there are four of these bands
maybe four each of the four universes
that get crossed over in this movie the
mcu the raimi verse the webverse and the
venomverse and as they illuminate the
room you can see that the blue merc that
previously surrounded them dissipates
presumably that was going to be the cold
and drowsy humor that doctor strange was
trying to conjure to just simply erase
people's memories but now the golden
reality warp bands tear the room to
pieces around them now that we've seen
venom let their re-carnage that movie's
post-credit scene seems to be showing a
similar process a bright golden light
fills the room and then reality warps
the room's decor that could explain why
we have all these random odds and ends
in this dungeon later on it's just a
bunch of crap that got redecorated after
the reality warped i've compared this
imagery to wanda maximoff's reality
warping in one division and i still
believe strange might be under wanda's
spell which is clearly what wandavision
was setting up and could explain why
strange so willingly helps peter warp
reality because remember wanda is
looking for a reality where her children
could still be alive moving on
from every
universe
hello peter i love it green goblin is
here he looms in through the smoke of
his own pumpkin grenades riding his
glider meanwhile strange explains that
these visitors are coming from every
universe meaning doctor strange might
have been previously aware of alternate
universes like the raimi verse which
would give interesting meaning to the
line he said to tony stark back in
infinity war protecting your reality
douchebag then electro's bolts blast
through the ground toward peter who
wears this new black and gold suit this
suit's kind of a mess there's loose
wires poking out duct tape all over the
place actually later you can see mj and
ned are on a smartphone duct taped to
his chest apparently facetiming all this
i am guessing this mission might be to
catch electro and they have to do it in
a way without peter's iron spider armor
maybe by turning his old suit inside out
so all the wiring is now exposed or
maybe his nanotech suit can't be relied
on after he ran into doc ock or this
could just be a new suit that they
rigged up to be more resistant to high
voltage let's move on to the next clip
you're not peter parker
ah yes license plates so i pointed out
in past videos how the cars on this
bridge seems to have specific license
plates that could be pointing to
specific comic book issues something
spider-man director john watts actually
does in all of his movies here doc and
peter passed a plate reading
jnd79wn which doesn't seem to directly
translate to anything in particular
unless maybe you try to stretch j and d
being for jessica drew spider-woman who
did first appear in marvel comics in
1976
but later here is a clearly overt one
asm 8183 john watts always uses asm to
refer to amazing spider-man and then a
specific comic book issue followed by
the year but this could be interpreted a
couple different ways actually there was
a spectacular spider-man not amazing
spider-man issue 81 in 83 which mixes up
spider-man with cloak and dagger
punisher and a certain bald baddie who's
gonna come stomping into the mcu soon
shrek i mean kingpin yes i have
theorized that kingpin wilson fisk could
be revealed in hawkeye and could be the
sixth villain of the sinister six in
this movie but alternatively there's
also an amazing spider-man number 183
that was released in august 8th month in
the year 1973 in which peter gets
attacked by a big wheel while aunt may
is hospitalized this could just be a
joke about how the wheel of this car is
flying at peter right now but then
beneath the bridge doc ock jams his claw
at peter and i love how john watts uses
a whip pan the same kind of camera
movement that sam raimi would often use
for dock in the 2004 film but notice how
doc ock's arms now have a red and gold
coating to them and a chunk of peter's
nanotech is missing from his chest he
actually has to reallocate the nanobots
from his helmet to his chest to protect
himself from the blow in a later trailer
shot shows that doc ock straight up
absorbs peter's nanotech armor from his
suit and this is crazy because doc ock
comes from an alternate universe where
stark tech does not exist how can it be
compatible with this tech well if you
think about it his arms are actually
controlled via a neural link that was
fused to spinal cord and stark nanotech
seems to be controlled via a kind of
neural link as well so maybe that is how
doc ock can hack into it i'm just
excited to see nanotech on the loose in
the mcu could be a major plot point in
shows like armor wars also a little vfx
detail that i appreciate peter's necktie
dangles from the open nanotech hole
where his chest is but as that nanotech
shifts and seals that hole it tucks the
necktie back in meanwhile when tom
holland's face is revealed doc ock says
you're not peter parker answering our
questions from the first trailer as to
why doc would see this version of
spider-man and recognize him as peter
from his universe it's just because doc
ock saw someone i guess who looked like
spider-man and assumed that would be
toby's face underneath but what i like
about this line is it does confirm the
existence of a toby maguire peter parker
somewhere in this merged spider-verse
and makes his cameo even more likely
let's move on
i'm sorry what was your name again dr
otto octavius
[Laughter]
wait no seriously what's your actual
name
sounds like the kids are okay boomerang
doc ock about his name i like how ned is
holding a crossbow might have been
something he picked up from strange and
wong's artifacts that they use for
things like vampire hunting because we
know a lot of these are coming in the
mcu meanwhile mj's necklace i love this
detail it's actually a broken piece of
the black dahlia necklace that peter
bought for her in venice and later ended
up broken when he gave it to her in that
movie she's so loyal what a keeper but i
mean it's mj she likes it better than
it's broken and then here we see how doc
actually retains the red and gold
nanobots from peter's suit on his arms
he might have actually absorbed all of
the nanobots for all we know and then as
doc turns his head these claws like
snakeheads turn their heads too we're
not really sure how much these arms are
listening to him or he's listening to
them i like to think they listen to me
now next clip
there are others out there we need to
send them back
so
scooby doo this crap you know all this
is kind of your mess i know a couple of
magic words myself starting with the
word please
please
scooby-doo this crap okay amazing set
piece here the freaking statue of
liberty keeping the tradition of
landmark set pieces like the washington
monument the venice grand canal tower
bridge in london but now with huge
cranes over it attaching a massive
captain america shield you can see a
banner hanging from the scaffolding
reading lady liberty the newest avenger
and you can actually see those words on
a bus stop ad for it later on now we
just saw liberty island used as an
example of how the world has gone to
crap during the blip with all the loose
boats moored up to it but now it seems
as though the government is using lady
liberty as a way of celebrating the
avengers victory for when cap stood his
ground facing the abyss and found backup
from opening portals behind him as we
pray peter parker will receive some
backup from other peters in this scene
if you remember this was kind of
foreshadowed and far from home when
mysterio's illusion trapped peter in a
snow globe where the statue of liberty
rose up beside him and earlier peter
stood among giant statues of his fallen
avenger heroes with him standing on a
giant captain america shield now of
course using the statue of liberty as a
final battle set piece has been
something that pretty much all superhero
movies have avoided because it was done
back in one of the first big marvel
movies x-men in 2000 which is the marvel
movie where kevin feige got his start as
an associate producer we're coming full
circle with that and i think there's a
deliberate reason for that i'll get to
it at the end of the video getting the
answers to these questions is quite a
quest for me yes i feel like i'm on my
own campbellian heroes journey and in my
own life i like to document my progress
by staging it this way and an awesome
new thing to help me do that is hero's
journal hero's journal is here to help
you accomplish your goals by turning
them into a quest the heroes journal
helps you discover the story you tell
about yourself and define the quest you
want to undertake they have two
different journals the istoria magic
academy for fans of harry potter and the
legend of astoria for folks more aligned
with lord of the rings and they have a
special new leather edition of the
journal made from vegan leather the
adventurers edition it's got fancy
foiling on the spine a lovely green
cloth ribbon that would just be a really
great gift to get someone whatever your
goals involve the hero's journal guides
you along the journey to achieving them
by building a positive narrative about
productivity versus a shame based
narrative you can try the first 71 pages
of the journal for free online if you
want to check it out that way but the
hero's journal is available for purchase
now head to theheroesjournal.co
or click the link in the description and
use promo code new rockstars for your 10
off they're running a black friday sale
for 30 off all of their journals except
the adventurer model but you can still
use our discount code new rockstars for
10 off that one and thanks again to
heroes journal for sponsoring this video
so electro is charging up using
electrical towers meanwhile peter uses a
piece of wrist tech that eliminates
rings of eldritch magic from doctor
strange so must be this suit or maybe
even just this piece on his wrist was
probably given to peter in order to
snare villains like elektro kind of like
a ghostbuster using a proton pack and a
trap then doctor strange tells them to
scooby-doo this crap just another
example of the mcu folding in all of pop
culture into their universe kind of like
how eternals just cited other warner
properties like superman and batman and
then a preview clip of hawkeye mentioned
katniss everdeen from hunger games but
strange telling them to scooby-doo this
problem does cast this group as a kind
of mystery inc like mj would be velma
peter probably shaggy ned scooby and
happy and aunt may fred and daphne
they're useless and always trying to
why don't you mind your own business pal
but like in scooby doo the kids of this
movie might end up unmasking the real
villain behind it all which according to
scooby doo lore is more often than not
the old man jenkins who hired them in
the first place so just add this to the
list of reasons to be super suspicious
of doctor strange in this movie he may
be the witch who would have gotten away
with it if it weren't for that meddling
nedlin moving on
you're flying out into the darkness
to fight ghosts what do you mean
they all die fighting spiderman
it's their fate
so we see a combination of electro and
sandman attacking cops and news vans but
now standing inside the daily bugle van
is our man jk simmons it's j jonah
jameson giddy smile on his face as he
realizes he's getting a great scoop and
as electro blasts away you can see his
humanoid shape flashing like lightning
from spot to spot now of course his
lightning color is now yellow not blue
like in the amazing spider-man 2 but
since doc ock can absorb nanotech i
think a lot of these villains might
adapt new features as they transition
into the mcu i love doc ock chilling us
with this line you're flying out into
the darkness
to fight ghosts for one it doubles down
on this ghostbusters parallel of peter's
mission but also alfred molina is
looking directly into the camera here as
if this is how he shuts up those kids
for laughing about his name reminding
them that they will be facing madmen who
should be dead who now think that
they're in some kind of purgatory or
hell and therefore they have nothing to
lose dr strange says that all these
people died fighting their version of
spider-man but that definitely wasn't
the case for sandman at the end of
spider-man 3. peter parker forgave him
and let him go making us wonder geez
toby what did you do after spider-man 3.
did flynn marco break your damn door fix
this
then peter leaps after a pumpkin grenade
as it explodes in front of him this
actually looks like the lobby of that
same building the one with the police
cars outside the same one we later see
electro on sandman outside of in the
lobby that aunt may seems to be charging
through i also think based off of the
swat swarming around it that is where
happy hogan is so ugh between happy and
may that's two very worrisome options
for who this pumpkin grenade may be
targeting but peter does seem to be
wearing a new incarnation of his iron
spider nanotech that probably protects
him from this explosion you can see that
gold emblem stretching across his
shoulders that's completely new the
guy's got a million suits in this
franchise and in that shot he appears to
be talking to aunt may after the
explosion so i'm thinking she'll be okay
happy though i don't know but an
explosion does destroy the entrance
emitting a green fire which actually
continues to burn green on that piece in
the lower right so i'm wondering that
this could be part of goblin's weaponry
and then on the right is a beast truck
feast is peter parker's homeless
outreach organization and it has a big
hole torn out of the side of the truck
like someone might have used this truck
as perhaps a trojan horse that they
burst out of in the attack moving on i'm
sorry kid
yeah me too don't
look there has to be another way there
isn't
they're a danger to our universe so
deciding that he does not want to send
these villains to their certain deaths
either realizing that if he's worthy of
redemption so must they be or after a
mysterio he doesn't want any villain
blood on his hands peter whips and
snatches that green cube artifact as it
levitates between strange's hands i'm
assuming this is some kind of pokeball
pocket prison that dr strange is either
storing the villains inside of or some
kind of mechanism that allows him to
return them to sender i love this peter
is strung between two portals strange
must have tricked peter by opening one
portal in the direction he was already
whipping and then another one
immediately behind him so that peter
ended up whipping his own foot genius
but in this shot i mentioned before aunt
may looks super emotional and she's
carrying some device looks metallic
cylindrical and glowing green a bit
could this be some form of goblin's tech
then doc ock tries to crush peter's head
which then leads to the nanobot
spreading across his mechanical arms
this actually might have been a defense
mechanism by the nanobots to keep the
claws from crushing the helmet but then
those bots fused with otto's neural link
allowing him to inherit them onto the
next clip
you're not gonna take this away from me
you're struggling
to have
everything you want
while the world tries to make you choose
so peter swings through the scaffolding
at the base of the statue of liberty but
you'll notice the statue is bronze
colored not the green color we know
today that's because when the statue was
originally assembled in france in the
1880s its copper plating made it a dull
brown color and then over the next 30
years it oxidized green the color we now
know it as so maybe this statue is
actually restored as part of its newest
avenger redo actually in shots of peter
perched on the crown you can see streaks
of green in those spikes as if this
oxidation was being scrubbed off then we
get our first clear look at jamie foxx
as electro he wears this chunky gear
that seems to help conduct the electric
current and it all seems to be stemming
from a chest component that almost looks
like an arc reactor like a spare one
from stark's tech just be another piece
of stark tech that one of these spidey
villains could hijack and repurpose he
does seem to fire a powerful blast that
seems like it's a mixture of repulsor
blasts and then i love this as the
electricity courses over his head it
makes the yellow starburst shape of
elektro's classic spark mask from the
comics then we get a nice close-up of
green goblin on his glider as well as a
quick flash of a goblin without his
helmet wearing flight goggles i'm just
thinking this is a blurry willem dafoe
face because if alternate goblins or
hobgoblin was in this movie i don't
think they would reveal james franco
ordained a han goblin in a shot like
this but you'll notice he drops in with
a swarm of razor bats you remember those
nasty things from the first raimi film
and then a dodc swat unit swarms in on
the building department of damage
control these are the authorities who
arrested interrogate peter and they seem
to hear it be in the apparent aftermath
of that green explosion and then a
juiced up version of doctor strange's
spell blast out from liberty island
expanding far into the sky maybe that
cube broke open causing the barriers
between realities to open even wider
more thoughts on this in a bit but onto
the next clip
this is all my fault i can't save
everyone
okay so electro sandman's giant face and
lizard leap across the statue of liberty
scaffolding towards spider-man but
clearly lizard is jumping towards
something else that must be positioned
beneath spider-man that's been scrubbed
from the frame actually in the brazilian
version of this trailer the cut was left
long enough to show lizard recoiling as
if something kicked him in the head
something that was removed from this
trailer and i think it's a very good
chance that in the theatrical version of
the scene that is going to be andrew
garfield spider-man maybe toby maguire
spider-man but garfield peter has a
history with lizard actually elektra was
also an andrew peter villain sandman was
the toby peterville and tom's really the
odd one out here but this shot just
makes it seem like it's three versus one
but compositionally it makes far more
sense for this to be three versus three
kind of like how the profile collision
shot in civil war was equal numbers on
both sides and when peter tells aunt may
that he can't save everyone i think the
subtext to that is that he can't do it
alone and he's gonna get some in-game
style backup from his peter variants now
i fully respect sony for not putting
toby and andrew in the trailer but fans
have been so ravenous with speculation i
think it's a foregone conclusion at this
point still i think we're gonna scream
like doc brown when we see them let's
move on
so the giant captain america shield
crashes through the scaffolding causing
ned and mj to lose their balance and mj
falls in slow motion with framing pretty
similar to gwen stacy's fault in the
amazing spider-man 2. peter dives after
her reaching out his hand is he going to
catch her while many are asking whose
hand this actually is it's definitely
tom holland peter parker's hand based on
the glove design in the new suit he is
wearing in the sequence but the
parallels to andrew garfield peter
parker and gwen stacy's death are pretty
strong enough here that it would not
surprise me if sony pulls another vfx
switcheroo and replaces tom's hand with
the life-saving grasp of shrek i'm
kidding andrew garfield who would refuse
to let another peter parker love
interest die the same way his gwen
stacey did you'll notice that the two
hands here are framed perfectly with one
world trade center in the background
just as this building does looming over
gwen stacy's funeral in the 2014 film
let's move on to the final clip what's
happening
they're starting to come through
and i can't stop him
so it looks as though that spell that
blasted outward from the statue of
liberty has left this crack in the sky
like the cracks in space formed when the
multiverse shattered and loki or the
shattering of reality walls and what if
now these cracks were once orange like
the golden bands of dr strange's spell
but now a purple glow has overtaken the
orange color as this glows in from what
lays beyond purple has tended to be the
color of dark magic in the mcu the color
of dormammu in the dark dimension the
color of agatha harkness's dark magic
but the question is what or who has
started to come in through these cracks
that doctor strange cannot keep out well
interdimensional threats like dormammu
or schuma gorath or demons from the what
if episode four always seem to be a
threat to doctor strange maybe we're
looking at a symbiote hive or kang
variants i don't think it has to be one
big threat but like the sinister six
spawning throughout the mcu any number
of out of place outsiders suddenly
appearing from different universes and i
think it is interesting that they chose
the statue of liberty as the focal point
of all of this the gateway to a new
world for the tire the poor the huddled
masses yearning to breathe free a symbol
chosen specifically for that x-men final
battle for that reason as part of
magneto's plan to transform world elites
into poor huddled mutants from a shining
beacon in lady liberty's torch no way
home is clearly a prelude to doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness
which i'm pretty sure is going to be the
mcu's version of the scarlet witch house
of the m storyline which is the nexus
point of mutant existence in the
multiverse if we are seeing the moment
that break in reality occurs and if
doctor strange has any link whatsoever
to the scarlet witch which we know from
one division that he does then kevin
feige might have chosen the statue of
liberty specifically for that parallel
symbolism as the place that he when he
got his start as a young associate
producer on that x-men 2000 film
personally shepherded marvel superheroes
to take a huge leap forward on the big
screen and he could be now bringing it
full circle as a place mutant kind
arrives on the shores of the mcu well
that is everything i caught in this
magnificent no way home trailer but we
will be making plenty more videos about
this in the days and weeks to come so
support this channel by checking out our
merch options at newrockstarsmerch.com
follow me on instagram and twitter at
eavos following your rockstar subscribe
to rockstars for breakdowns of
everything you love it's late in the
night i can't talk anymore
[Music]
you
[Music]